ja wir kommen zu einer neuen sendung zu
einer neuen podcast bei philo cast heute
mit dr
christopher erhard hallo christopher
christopher du bist ein mann darf schon
sagen ein experte im bereich der
phänomenologie kannst du unseren
zuhörerinnen und zuhörern mal ganz kurz
zu erklären was es mit der
philosophischen phänomenologie
eigentlich so auf sich hat
vielen dank für die einladung ich würde
sagen vermag kann man es ist vielleicht
ganz hilfreich sich von der
wortbedeutung von der wortbedeutung
auszugehen und ich würde da drei aspekte
unterscheiden einmal die die historische
dimension ist manchmal eine bestimmte
richtungen dafür soll die vor allem
metro style anfängt mit montez saal dann
zweitens eine bestimmte methode auf die
wir vielleicht dann im laufe des
gesprächs noch mehr eingehen können also
eine bestimmte art zu philosophieren
sage ich mal die sich vor allem darauf
konzentriert was renault logan als
irgendwie selbst gegebenheit oder wesens
anschauung der dinge die als solche
bezeichnen
und was man eher so heute wenn man eine
einführung in die analytische
philosophie des geistes oder das aus
schlägt dann ist oft von phänomenologie
oder vernommen und consciousness die
rede
das ist eine relevante bedeutung aber
denke ich man muss man muss ein bisschen
aufpassen dass nicht mit der vg als
methode oder bewegung gleichzusetzen
also das als kleiner einen überblick
vielen dank du hattest jetzt schon eine
person genannt edmund hose der ist
vielleicht nicht allen unseren zuhören
inbegriff kannst du mal ganz kurz so ein
bisschen was über edmund russlands sagen
viele sagen er war so der begründer der
phänomenologie was ist kann man das muss
man über ihn wissen um die phänologie
besser zu verstehen
ja
also muss er gilt als der begründer der
hat eben diesen ausdruck finden den gab
es auch schon davor in der philosophie
also der taucht bei hegel auch aufbau
bei kant auf denen nur geht des geistes
über hegel beispiel in der form richtig
aber fußball hat diesen ausdruck
wirklich für eine bestimmte art des
philosophierens und nach russland auch
eine systematische art des
philosophierens eingeführt und ich kann
einfach mal mit einem zitat anfang so
rüssel in seiner schrift ideen zu einer
reinen philosophie und technologischen
philosophie von 19 13 sagt dann einmal
in paragraf 75 phänomenologie als er
definiert sie geradezu als deskriptive
wesens lehre der reinen erlebnisse
das ist so eine formel mit der man ein
bisschen arbeiten könnte also was darin
zum ausdruck kommt ist es geht bei uns
zum erlebnis das es sind bewusstseins
vorkommnisse in denen uns die welt und
alles worüber wir reden erscheint
erscheint und vor allem deskriptiv es
geht darum zu beschreiben was diese
erlebnisse für wesentliche eigenschaften
haben und dann gesagt auch noch sie es
soll rein sein also reine deskriptive
wesens lehre damit mein trost sein dass
diese beschreibungen nicht von unseren
natürlichen vorurteilen ausgehen sollen
und auch nicht irgendwelche
wissenschaftlichen annahmen divers der
physik oder den naturwissenschaften
haben dass wir die nicht einfach
übertragen auf die weise wie wir und wie
wir die welt erfahren sondern wir müssen
gewisse weise von vorne anfangen wenn
wir unsere beziehung zur welt unser
bewusstsein von der welt verstehen
wollen das interesse erinnert mich jetzt
recht an die karts rené descartes der ja
auch so ganz von vorne anfangen möchte
der sich erst mal fragt was kann
überhaupt wissen und dann stufenweise
sich nach vorne tastet kannst du ein
bisschen was sagen über das verhältnis
von hussel und descartes rathaussaal
auch was geschrieben ich glaube
katalanische meditationen wie es dieses
verhältnis zu denken
also hat er sehr hoch geschätzt
neben platon und jugend es waren
seine will seine lieblings philosophen
also die es gibt ähnlichkeiten und
unterschiede natürlich also eine
ähnlichkeit
sie kann man daran sehen dass descartes
das ist asozial ähnlich wie descartes
eben versucht so eine art anfang des
philosophierens zu finden und der ist
ähnlich wie bei die karten eben im
eigenen bewusstsein von der welt also
das denke ich ist eine überschneidung
punkt russland hat dem vatikan immer
vorgeworfen dass er sozusagen zu früh
angefangen hat gewissermaßen wird wieder
der traditionelle metaphysik zu machen
also bei der cards gibt es dann gottes
beweise also die karts versucht dann aus
dem bewusstsein durch beweise oder
schlüssel irgendwie die die außenwelt
wieder die existenz der außenwelt zu
beweisen so was würde russland usa
kategorisch ab er würde sagen wir müssen
das bewusstsein in seinen ganzen
vielfältigen strukturen immer weiter
beschreiben analysieren und es ist
methodisch falsch dann anzufangen von
irgendwie etwas im bewusstsein auf etwas
zu schließen was eigentlich gar nicht im
bewusstsein direkt zugänglich ist also
diese übergänge vom bewusstsein auf
etwas was eigentlich nicht dem
bewusstsein direkt zugänglich ist das
ist sozusagen verwundert an
also das ist etwas was fergie nicht tun
sollte ok jetzt könnte man aber auch
einwenden die phänomenologie kommt dann
doch gar nicht zu außenwelt den dingen
außer mir also sind wir dann nicht nur
solistisch gefangenen uns was könnte man
den stars phänologische oder rosalie
amische respektiv wieder auf antworten
also ich denke es würde sagen es ist es
ist ein missverständnis dass man
irgendwie von der philosophie erwarten
sollte dass sie zum beispiel die
existenz der außen- oder dergleichen
irgendwie beweis oder herleitet sondern
muss er sagt man hat eine starke an
einer stelle es geht nicht darum
objektive objektivität zu sichern sagt
er da sondern zu verstehen als er will
sozusagen nicht beweisen dass es die
welt gibt oder dass wir mit unseren
erkenntnis ansprüchen immer oder das ist
kein beweis geben oder lang sondern
verstehe ist interessiert ihn vielmehr
wie wir überhaupt dazu kommen dinge für
objektiv existieren zu setzen anzunehmen
und das ist dann hier sozusagen das
paradox oder mit das problem mit dem
operiert also die welt ist uns immer nur
subjektiven perspektive gegeben also sie
ist uns nie unabhängig von uns von
unserer perspektive geben und trotzdem
halten wir sie oder setzten wir sie für
etwas objektives und es geht ja darum
das zu verstehen wie wir das tun also
ein klassisches beispiel vielleicht kann
ich darauf eingehen also sein hat sehr
viel über wahrnehmung von räumlichen
dingen von dingen im raum geschrieben
und hier haben wir so schon so scheint
ein gewisses paradox dass wir wir sehen
die dinge immer nur aus einer
perspektive wir sehen sie nie als ganze
aber trotzdem sehen wir jetzt mag oder
meinen wir die dinge selbst zu sehen und
nicht nur unsere abstatte unsere
perspektiven
naja und horst als aufgabe ist dann
sozusagen zu beschreiben wie das
zustande kommt unser glaube dass da
etwas objektives mit unendlich vielen
möglichen perspektiven und aspekten ist
dass es so etwas gibt obwohl wir sie nur
einseitig sehen und touristen würde dann
eine genaue gibt dann eine genaue
analyse dass das vor allem dadurch
geschieht dass ich mich bewegen kann im
raum von verschiedenen seiten das ding
sehen kann und dabei die früheren seiten
immer noch im bewusstsein behalten muss
dass es muss eine kontinuierliche
synthese sagte wie ich die dinge
identifiziere als etwas identisches
geben
es geht um diese beschreibung der
leistungen die wir als bewusstseins fair
gewesen zu tun im stande sind aufgrund
deren uns zum beispiel ein ding als
objektives ding erscheint du hast jetzt
sehr anschaulich erklärt dass es also
russland um die objektivität dämlich
gedacht geht sozusagen um das außen also
uns
um die bedingung der möglichkeit könnte
man vielleicht auch sagen von
objektivität und das ist natürlich sehr
an immanuel kant und seine
transzendentale philosophie kann denkt
ja auch alles vom subjekt er von seinen
kategorien von die transzendentale die
option die es auch aufgehängt an diesem
höchsten einheits punktes des
selbstbewusstseins wie verhalten sich
dem jetzt und kant zueinander wenn es
darum geht subjektivität zu begründen
oder auch die außenwelt und die
objektivität zu erklären auf eine
gewisse transzendentale art und weise ja
also das ist sehr komplexes verhältnis
also die die anknüpfung an kant ist
sicher dabei haus sein
ich kann vielleicht zwei punkte
herausgreifen wo ich denke das ist halt
einfach so zu sagen ich will sagen noch
ein stück weiter oder tiefe geschickt
tiefer schürfen würde als kant also
bekannt ist es ja so dass die also wie
eine kritik der reinen vernunft vorgeht
dass er die effekte mit den urteilen der
der mathematik kann also diesen
berühmten synthetischen urteilen und
fragt sich dann wie die möglich sind und
diese synthetischen urteile gab ulrike
zu holen der mathematik als auch in als
auch in form von prinzipien der natur
wissenschaft also hier würde wusste an
einer stelle einsetzen und sagen das ist
sozusagen schon mit einer
wissenschaftlichen welt beschreibung
anfängt also kannst schon anfängt
entschuldigung kann tja und fußball
interessiert sich was er dann die
lebenswelt nennt also russland
interessiert dann schon wie wir ganz
normal im alltag ein dingen diesen tisch
hier den ich greifen mit dem ich
praktisch umgehen kann wie ich über den
überhaupt den schon als ding setzt also
er würde noch eine stufe tiefer anfangen
als kant und ein zweiter punkt der sitzt
nicht so leicht so dass müsste man dann
genauer beschreiben aber im rüssel
hatten etwas probleme sage ich mal
salopp mit mit so transzendentalen
argumenten die also muss er wollte immer
beschreiben und mehr also wollte zwar
auch auf bedingung der möglichkeit gehen
aber er hat so eine gewisse abneigung
dazu von bestimmten prämissen die wir
haben oder für selbstverständlich halten
dann zu schließen durch transplantate
argumente was
für der fall sein muss vielleicht nur
sagen beispiel mit der kausalität
bekannt also kausalität ist ja bekannt
nicht dies so zu sagen ich war also die
es nicht wahrnehmbar
die die kommt durch den verstand und
unser verstand muss diese kategorie
schon haben um die er sinneseindrücke zu
strukturieren
also ich würde an der stelle so
einsetzen und sagen na ja ist es
eigentlich so klar dass wir kausale
beziehung gar nicht wahrnehmen können
also kosten würde und ich glaube das
würde das auch behaupten und das
kausalität auch ein phänomen sein kann
also diese kategorien bekannt wurde
musste an einigen stellen sicher sagen
dass wenn die noch also wir dürfen die
nicht als etwas rein postuliert dass
setzen sondern wir müssen versuchen so
weit wie möglich beschreibungen zu geben
aber vielleicht kann ich nur ergänzen
werden jetzt schon so viel bewusster
gerät also man kann ich meine es in
meiner auffassung dass die film gehe es
gibt sozusagen er die subjektorientierte
oder fokussierte phänologie dazu gehört
vor allem host als vertreter und als
zentrale frage ist wie wie macht es
unser bewusstsein unserer subjektiven
erfahrungen dass sie ihm objektive dinge
erscheinen können und eine eher objekt
gerichtet oder objekt zentrierte könnte
man vielleicht sagen richtung in der
phänologie die wird von autoren würde
ich sagen wie adolf reinach das sehr
unbekannt aber aber frei nach zb und
eventuell auch max scheler und einige
andere die oft zur realistischen firmen
gerichtet werden also die machen ich
denke es gibt da es gibt etwas gemeinsam
ist was diese von logan mit stahlteilen
motiv an sozusagen er direkt an und
fragen sich zum beispiel ganz direkt
was ist denn das wesen eines materiellen
dingen und dazu muss man nicht diesen
umweg machen über sozusagen die
subjektive erscheinungsweise okay du
würdest also sagen rusal ist jede
subjektivität theoretische
phänomenologie und andere wir ein nach
china sind hier die objektivität
theoretischen filmen ja das muss ich
nicht aus es wird oft so dargestellt
dass das irgendwie so sich
ausschließende lager sind also ich denke
was sie eben teilen das was ich ganz am
anfang gesagt habe ist diese methode
dass wir durch beschreibung und ein
klamme hrung von naturwissenschaftlichen
annahmen versuchen wesens eigenschaften
heraus zu reparieren
nicht so sehr irgendwie schlüsse zu
konstruieren oder theorien oder
erklärungen zu konstruieren sondern eben
dieses anschauliche beschreiben das
teilen beide nur einmal so zu sagen er
auf das bewusstsein fokussiert einmal
gewissermaßen direkt an den auf die
dinge fokussiert hat
das heißt du würdest jetzt phänologie
durchaus als was er weiter fassen dass
verschiedene philosophische disziplin
auch behandeln kann also man könnte
sagen sagen phänomenologische kann ich
an und logische fragen herangehen ich
kann aber auch vielleicht auf praktische
fragen zu gehen sagte ist ja auch ein
philosoph der mir jetzt noch kam auf den
du noch nicht eingegangen bist wie
würdest du den zart und vielleicht dann
auch davor schon heiliger in ein
verhältnis zur phänomenologie bringen
nur so ganz kurz unsere zuhörerinnen und
zuhörer also so hajduk es schon fangen
wir vielleicht mit heiliger andersartige
würde ich sagen
also heiliger hat auch würde ich sagen
diese idee übernommen das genau
beschreiben und spricht dann auch von
auslegung der phänomene
er war ja ein schüler von llosa war ein
schüler von roßtal und er sagt dann zum
beispiel ganz programmatisch in sein und
zeit in der einleitung
also man kann phänologie nur als
ontologie und umgekehrt ist eigentlich
und logie auch als phänomenologie
möglich das liegt eben daran dass man
diese idee des phänomens also das ist
beide gesagt das ist das was ich an ihm
selbst herr zeigt dass sich selbst
zeigen de
da steckt wieder die idee dahinter dass
wir sozusagen die dinge über die wir
reden in einer direkten in einem
direkten zugang und irgendwie auf die
beziehen und dann darüber urteilen und
beschreiben beide erst dann sozusagen
einen clou würde ich sagen dass er eben
sagt das onkologie geht es um das sein
oder designs weise der der dinge und
gerade das sein müssen wir für logisch
beschreiben weil das sein dasjenige ist
was dazu tendiert sich in unserem
alltäglichen umgang zu entziehen oder
was wir immer schon als
selbstverständlich an setzten deswegen
müssen wir es so zu sagen ausdrücklich
zum phänomen machen und deswegen ist
phänologie auch eine methode und
theologie zu machen nennt er sein
berühmtes das sein und das nichts im
untertitel versuch einer phänomenologie
also da hat er beide ausdrücke
fusioniert seite würde ich auch so zart
ist so ein bisschen so ein hybrid
gewissermaßen aus roßtal und heiliger
und seite macht es auch so dass es sehr
viel genaue beschreibungen von
alltäglichen phänomenen gibt zb der
angst der erfahrung von freiheit und
dann kommt sozusagen ein zweiter schritt
hin zu dass dann heiliger vater versucht
diese phänomene und die merkmale diese
phänomene zu fundieren
er fragt sich dann eine typische frage
die sich stellt wie mussten das subjekt
oder der mensch beschaffen sein
damit er diese und jene phänomene
erleben kann wenn sie so sind wie sie
sich zeigen
diese frage hatte ihr heiliges so nicht
direkt gestellt sprach er vom dasein
aber ja selten von menschen direkt ne
könnte man sagen dass da tritt
vielleicht dann noch so eine gewisse
anthropologische dimension in diese
phänomenologische diskussion mit
einbringt ja ich sehe ehrlich sagt sato
und heiliger nicht so weit voneinander
entfernt also heiliger spricht von
dasein oder existenz sagt er spricht
richtiger also stimmt er spricht mehr
von er spricht von der realität
menschliche realität ist so ein ausdruck
realität aber ich würde sagen das ist
nicht so ein wesentlicher unterschied
also im sattel interessiert sich eben
was für wesen wir sind die die
bewusstseins fähig sind und die und der
versuchte ihm das wesen des menschen
anhand von ausgezeichneten phänomenen zu
beschreiben also das ist ein bisschen
schon anders als fußball also beiseite
und heiliger steht schon mehr so zu
sagen wenn ich so sagen darf der mensch
in seiner konkreten existenziellen
situation im vordergrund da muss man
immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
also sagte war auch er wird oft so
verstanden als hätte nur so eine art
anthropologie gemacht aber satte war
eigentlich immer interessiert an
metaphysik genau diese negativität die
er für seine freiheitsliebe sehr wichtig
ist
wir hatten auch mal ein seminar
gemeinsam angeboten zu diesem thema ja
jetzt haben wir sehr viel über
historische positionen gesprochen und
habilitiert dich ja auch gerade über
seine technologische arbeit die stärker
die handlungs theorie ins zentrum rückt
und das wäre seine abschlussfrage durch
diese zweite teil des interviews
könntest du so ein bisschen was über die
neuere entwicklung der phänomenologie
sagen also häufig stand sicherlich
phänomenologie so ein bisschen im ruf im
schlechten rufs ein bisschen altbacken
zu sein sage jetzt mal aus
perspektiven also in der rolle heidegger
und der saat und dann noch die kleineren
vereine monologen die ja häufig ein
bisschen idiosynkrasien auch formuliert
haben diese ganz komischen begriffe
heidecker hat das in der welt sein und
auch kussa hat ja sehr seltsame auf den
ersten blick jedenfalls seltsame
begriffe geprägt wo dann sicherlich die
analytische philosophie grund hat es
hatte zu sagen was soll denn jetzt mit
denen anfangen kannst du so ein bisschen
unseren zu hören und zuhören mal
beschreiben wie sich so die neue
philosophie zu dieser phänomenologischen
tradition verhält gibt es ansätze
vielleicht philosophien philosophen die
in dieser tradition stehen und die auch
wirklich systematisch beiträge leisten
können zu aktuellen oder immer noch
relevanten fragestellungen wie fällt die
da so ein
also was ist denke ich so in den letzten
10 20
vielleicht schon 30 jahren also schon
passiert ist würde ich sagen dass in der
analytischen philosophie des geistes
also wird den klassischen änderungen
deutlich mehr aufmerksamkeit geschenkt
das hat sicher damit zu tun dass in der
analytischen philosophie des geistes
also die rede über bewusst sein
phänomenales bewusstsein wie es ist
wie es sich anfühlt ein mensch zu sein
oder eine fledermaus zu sein in diesem
berühmten beispiel also dass das die
rede von bewusstsein nach so einer phase
von bhw juris muss und materialismus
also dass die wieder sozusagen
salonfähig geworden ist und in dem
zusammenhang gibt es im rückgriff auf
die die tradition die traditionellen
ferner monologen und ich versuche ja
auch in dieser richtung zu arbeiten und
also vielleicht also was eben da gesehen
wird also als einen analytischen
philosophen den man denke ich da
durchaus nennen kann ist die rajak
riegel der auch versucht von
bestimmten bewusstseins phänomenen wie
zb entscheidungen was ist eine
entscheidung typischer bewusster vorgang
was ist eine imagination was heißt das
etwas zu imaginieren also bezug so
einzelne phänomene da auf die tradition
zu sehen zu gucken und eben zu sehen
dass dort eben analysen gegeben sehr
reichhaltige komplexe beschreibung die
immer diese wie man sagt erste person
perspektive der beschreibung
berücksichtigen also wenn ich eine
entscheidung beschreibe das ist
wesentlich dafür dass ich das bin und
dass ich diese entscheidung auf eine
bestimmte weise erleben also es
schwierig zum beispiel sei das wie ein
entscheidung rein von außen oder nur
aufgrund ganz oder nur von außen also
indem man hirnscans macht oder
dergleichen oder körperbewegungen
betrachtet also das gehört alles
letztlich zu dem phänomen also ich will
nicht sagen wollen
es reicht nur die die reine
introspektion vielleicht oder dieser
diese beschreibung aufgrund der ersten
person perspektive aber die darf auf
keinen fall fehlen und es ist einfach so
dass die die was die psychologen da zu
bieten haben und meistens ist es auch
noch so gewissermaßen noch ein fass ohne
boden das ist alles noch nicht erschöpft
ist ebenso reichhaltig so differenziert
so notiert also dass da einfach immer
noch viel zu holen ist und vielleicht
noch ein anderer der von anfang an beide
traditionen also eher die analytische
philosophie des geistes als auch die
phänologischen wickert also wäre zum
beispiel denzer harvey aus kopenhagen zu
nennen bei denen wir auch studiert hast
für eine weile über dem ich ja
forschungsaufenthalt
forschungsaufenthalt gewesen bin und er
macht es halt eben genau mit dieser mit
diesem doppelten blick sozusagen
einerseits auf probleme die aktuell in
der philosophie des geistes gibt und
eben zu sehen was die verlogen dazu zu
sagen zu haben
ok ja also christopher vielen dank für
deine ausführlichen informationen über
die phänomenologie ich denke unsere
zuhörerinnen und zuhörer mich
eingeschlossen haben jetzt einen guten
einblick in diese materie
vielleicht gibt es auch eine zweite
sendung danach an die zuschauer zu hören
zuhörer bitte kommentare unten rein ins
video die beschreibung dann machen wir
vielleicht noch ein zweites video oder
zweite auto sendung fiel dank
christopher danke auch